popular man thank you man I hope you
have gotta be up in the office do red
pepper will be too costly talk about
ownership and average KPI detectors out
of everything so I think you just go
backwards
meaning you guys are so young I mean you
know in a world where everybody's a 15
year old founder now but you have to
understand how young you are like you
you could run this business 30 years
from tonight right it just comes down to
patient that I think you're in hi
I suggest the following I think the
thing that's too many young founders you
know make a mistake is they think
somebody else is going to beat them to
it without realizing how big it is
that's a fear of course it is again like
this is what I do I know this stuff yeah
if you came out and you feel like your
first and three major companies Disney
Steven my friend gets a billion dollars
and does it and new division does it
you'll still with this brand being
number four with all the money you have
none just have it you still can build a
50 million dollar business you
understand yet at the end yeah that's
the answer
yeah now you know hard it is to sell a
million dollars worth of stuff yeah
do you really know yet I'm super happy
like most most people never even come
remotely clear the fact that you not
only created IP you figured out so one
thing I would tell you that I would make
a serious recommendation is you need to
create Mickey Mouse the one thing I
don't see here that I want badly
character a hundred percent like all
this all this I want to see a little
face here whether it's that base or
something else what the only thing like
this is like amazing and even I'm like
oh maybe I should invest and help them
like this is amazing this is what I want
I love IP I love Marvel I love you know
DC Comics I love I mean where they
interview do I know you are but you're
not there in the
pterosaurs okay people are creating
birthday parties oh well we're just so
you know there's nothing you can say
that is going to surprise right yeah or
important trust me for that matter
because this is right yeah the back to
your ply no one in four babies in this
country yeah Latino one of four that's a
lot of baby [ __ ] yeah which is why I
still think you can be in fourth place
and building thirteen million dollar a
year business that kicks you three
million dollars in profit and I have a
funny feeling 1.5 listen you may want to
buy the New York Jets like I do but like
it's not too bad is it and so if you can
do that in six years so there's always a
deal to be made but not rushed into just
because you think it's time or because
you fear somebody's coming and will take
it that's the great beer I noticed it's
the cliche year of entrepreneurs that
haven't done it a couple times you don't
realize the biggest things this YouTube
audience on my blog doesn't realize is
that there's enough room to feed
everybody if you're good enough we
forget that
everybody forgets it everybody thinks
it's a zero-sum game yeah you think it's
a zero-sum game you think it's a
zero-sum game another zero sum game
there's enough blue that's a 97 best
free purveyor in the world is a
billionaire Wow got it yeah and by the
way that might not be true but it's in
season right you already got it and so
that's it a couple things that stand out
one you need a character and you need
multiple go relays right hey not
and I got an opportunity love people
chills love what's right I'm guessing
the most important person that are going
to staffing like this is where is one of
the biggest things they're still going
to need a real ninja there it's like
strategy right like you're going to need
somebody I think the answer is both and
and and if done right you pick the
person that is excited about helping
everybody get good at it not she or he
is insecure and creates a moat around
their skill set all right going on cagey
initial she's not letting us film in
here but you know the [ __ ] key
raucous bands going into the fourth film
stealing alright to crush that guy
yeah that's perfect like I'm like real
TV YouTube I'd much rather honest with
you I love you next year to me a big
year
I think India's locked in I think
Brazil's locked in mainly on China
mainly in China India Brazil we need to
plan like [ __ ] crazy
I actually have a rogue idea what if in
January and February actually just go
international while the books out like
instead of doing like a US tour I just
do it globally something smart to be
done anyway my advice for everybody on
social media is content either
entertainment utility you know those are
the two places you need to go you even
need to bring value and smarts need to
motivate and excite entertain comedy you
know being attractive all these
different things they're just forms of
information that fill boredom or offset
the hardships about the real world right
and so you need to kind of figure out
who are you going to be like are you
going to be somebody who entertains are
you going to be somebody who informs are
you going to be somebody who's got a mix
of both you know how do you think about
it actually in South Africa I think is
on my line too with black coffee dinner
sports was good Dan and feel really
strong you know Derrick Morgan Braxton
Miller real established
are coming over working on some others
obsessive special-teams punters kickers
Turner's Gunners some fascinated by that
from marketing standpoint so just
enjoying it mark patience is the best
lesson if you watch carefully almost
everything I talk about is confidence in
patience humility and patience work
ethic and patience [ __ ] love patience
I've been real patient with all like the
energy I have and all the ability I have
I've been systematically patience [ __ ]
Oh anyway forgot Los Angeles if you're
in LA tonight 7:00 p.m. on Melrose Xu
Palace 7:00 to 9:00 meet-and-greet
answer some questions take some selfies
shake some hands here's a couple babies
bring your babies
I mean JP it's not just hustle hustle is
the most controllable you've got to be
smart I don't think we talked enough
about smartness strategy I'm going to
try to change that and talk a little bit
more about it but you know it's hard for
me to say hey Jordan get smarter right
Instagram make sure you love 7:00 p.m.
tonight Los Angeles pass it on Melrose
shoo Palace k-swiss generation K sneaker
drop these things right here all leading
to the more important thing which is in
November the Gary B sneaker drops if
basketball players and rappers can do it
so can I wear my parrot like boys need a
career so I be into my own man
all day 150 image pieces of content on
Facebook interims then we look at the
qualitative feedback and then we produce
the for commercials on the back of the
first hundred days of outdoor and print
outdoor imprints aka
Instagram and Facebook advertised for
today t'v in picture or animated gif
form got it can you guys do me a favor
can you make this slide today
can you show four or five of our best
videos I want to paint this narrative we
do Vlasic pickles and then we can target
the people that watched the Vlasic
pickles video all the way through with
call-to-action creative down at the mall
[ __ ] effect back to the manna is women
procrastinate people detest them without
passion evolution but like and like men
always pull screen like I'm finding
myself in a very interesting spot in my
life I'm a very successful company I've
done well in investing and over the last
year over the last 10 years I've been
building notoriety followings but over
the last year my profile has changed
quite a bit on the back of Instagram
mainly I just have a lot of people
paying attention to what I say now I
have this incredible ambition to rewire
what is considered cool to young men
around the world and make it far more
merit-based I don't think I'm being in
Fantasyland I'm definitely not trying to
over skew on current politically correct
trends but I'm definitely trying to
teach kids that like entrepreneurship is
not about champagne and models and
private jets and that tons of hard work
and being the bigger man and women in
every situation and sticking to your
word it's just old school [ __ ] and I
just think I'm a voice that's been able
to communicate to people so it's just a
very fun time in my life right now
so what this just ledger amazing ok
forward to more times together
stop joking don't dream right I have
behind our result
Barry how Lelaina we're going to be go
right on oh [ __ ] it's yes yet let's do a
neon money wait till I see me so what's
the score here can I guess the man
that's harder with like okay let's have
that conversation a thug yeah that's a
big one Swedes Gary I would love to know
would you hire someone who is not on
ecology risky of course I went to Mount
Ida College and basically played Madden
for four straight years and you're doing
okay yeah we don't require college I
mean even better it's not would we
vaynermedia does not require college
education to work at our company and I
would argue the people that are crushing
it the most are shitty students like me
and d-roc [ __ ] yeah this on music man
hey you got it
take care bye take care miss sever that
episode where I cooked in a rock are you
a good really productive meeting with a
client growing the relationship to the
next level you know one of the things
that I think a lot of businesses lack is
patience and investment upfront
it's a climb we lost money on in the
first year a lot of people wouldn't have
taken it I did
the reason ourselves and now we're
growing into a much bigger relationship
because the client recognizes the value
they've received and so these are fun
moments where you can see something
growing
you know it's like whether it's a flower
child alarm business you know those
really difficult things that you have to
do the first a couple years really make
an impact you know I've got friends of
complaining about dog right now like it
locked up like be trained it properly
and if you train your puppy properly in
the first couple months you reap the
benefits for next 13 to 15 years and uh
you know that's how I think about
business you've gotta over deliver over
execute provide so much value in that
first year to to make the benefits it's
tough in corporate America people change
people change jobs companies you know go
down in size and cut things that so I've
lost this that enormous amount of time
but the humans that watched me make that
investment remember and sometimes they
go to a different company and so it's a
classic example of like doing the right
thing is always the right thing and at
lunch meeting I just had was doing the
right thing
ending up in the right place
good afternoon facebook hope you're
doing well have been live on Facebook in
a while and look at it it's cool I'd
like there's similar features that
haven't seen yet good to see you guys
Andrew them Jones real quick by show of
hands who's in Los Angeles right now
anybody in LA tonight 7 p.m. to 9 p.m.
at shoe palace so cool live years Sony
wait a and so what you can integrate
these people onto your right yeah you
can call min so look if I hit Chris
Miller I invite him now he's invited and
I think he'll be able to just come in
for oak there's Chris Miller Chris all
right don't worry Chris do like how are
you
all right Legos Chris right that was fun
please tell all your homies all your
fellows that I'm going to be at Shoe
palace tonight 7:00 to 9:00 p.m. on
Melrose in Los Angeles signing some
sneakers maybe you know answering some
business questions mainly selfies how
many people you think are going to show
up tie I what's your official prediction
on official prediction of people that
show up is 1200 holy [ __ ] that much what
do you think I thought about that's
[Music]
really please guys I think I think yes
your your they put it on TV
that's your [ __ ] honor of them an 11
o'clock morning show on King Los Angeles
you think is going to drive but erock
your fire key breakfast
can we get Tyler bass at the fella
Babbitt if you're watching this can you
please get to this car ASAP we're on the
highway somewhere here I mean [ __ ]
they put it on TV that [ __ ] year do
you think it is vrock 1947 what the [ __ ]
I think there's over a thousand I mean
Cornell's post on the instagrams stories
is seen by more people than that [ __ ]
come on yeah no but I think you're
getting a little confused by how many
people RSVP'd on Facebook and don't show
up I'd be pumped if there was five
hundred people like bombed like you know
what five hundred people going to look
like on Melrose people maybe like who's
at the store like like some real athlete
you know just an entrepreneur thank you
my friends deploy with Nick's t96 things
make them run it back back back I'm back
against the wall but whenever backing
down at the mall [ __ ] back oh my life
is actually finding a perspective yeah
yeah it's amazing
wait wait wait wait weird shows way way
way more for it this is fun yeah I'm
real livable one of your business plans
actually
so one thing that you guys might not
know is that I think I'm one of the
great entertainers of a lifetime but I
cannot read so I would never be able to
do a show like this because my real
meaning is smooth yeah yeah it's just
I'm just not did it good at reading
can't we push it
I'm trying to take up the entire segment
with the bio what's your problem and
I'll just say thank you thanks for
having me
see ya sounds like a baby guys in my
life would you argue that was the
greatest segment in your show sister
I'll argue I'm in this video so I turned
it in it is I hope that all their love
never turned out love it this might be
this one is coming right listen you
designed yes but yeah it's looking cool
awesome love them that's like my Bible
this is what I'm gonna do they moved out
of state a small-town boy made it to the
big screen Cape Cod now Maui and next to
Drake gummies like yay get our
[ __ ] bass wait
they stopped reaching for they blame I
sitting I don't know how I guess with no
manners
wait yourself Rises John I just passed
I'm a [ __ ] your mother had a
black eye super fun fact he rocks
erection key rock your Direction skills
are not good they're amazing with
everything you're not good at direction
then I'm with you are you're with me
every [ __ ] minute be a little bit
tight
I share with Boehner experience to our
four DS DMA to my DNA to our what we did
for Bloomberg philanthropies every time
we do a fan base marketing of education
people love it and we need to be smarter
about that I think that's going to be in
each August is the quintessential
transition month in my opinion it's just
I'm obsessed with August I think it's
fascinating and I love this like you
know why because I think everybody wins
in August to me judging it it is the
month where both sides of the extremes
completely check the [ __ ] out or
completely all in our bring
disproportionate value and return to
your actions and of course you know
ninety percent of people can 95 percent
of people can do what they always do
every month regardless of August which
is be half pregnant in both sides the
YouTube the YouTube strategy like is
everything like youtube post Labor Day
for me is going to be like [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] obsessed
so so curious to see if we can pull it
off but I think we will thank you
very myself ugly frustrated it's good
manners good it's awesome all right
buddy
I love the man's continued success yeah
I appreciate it thank you thanks so much
I hurt myself again so I had to bring it
here had to let them knives no wild
state he understand crazy I'm ending
game plays just arrived nutty cystogram
whole thing about he should dive oh this
is selling out I love it I love business
I love bringing value and love fun and
positivity people don't get it
positivity always wins negativity always
loses it's just the truth like I love it
it's just like so black and white you do
the right thing the right things happen
and got out the patience and the
confidence winners can do that oh you're
still not there what kind of what kind
of logistics people are you what what
kind of logistics people are you look
look I mean this is not you know you
didn't have you didn't have the phone
call in my calendar you guys are jerking
off with each other yeah all right say
hello that's it this is the end of your
career but this one have tile around
he's a nice kid
there's a moment in your gun when when
the fire takes oh well as you know 27
feet slip challenge yet real quick we've
made three hundred dollars also consider
joke yes about that started drop
shipping business
yeah that was 40k three months ago thank
you for being that first domino
yeah yeah channel Facebook ass no
Instagram yet now or influencer
marketing a hundred talk tarnish with
your solar-powered it with legend you
want say anything right now yeah you
[ __ ] executed I'm proud right thank
you I'll see you again soon I know Oh
what are we good we're just stealing
following we're just for you have you
been nice is very good on you today
spreads of lock no [ __ ] here it is here
it is here it is thank you so happy
three minutes give me up if you need me
okay yep
[Music]
I thought thank you so so much
where's-where's uh Andy good [ __ ] man
thank you love you okay
babban thank you man tell Jordan I'm
sorry I hurt his feelings
see you too wakin me
[Music]
[Music]
pop you do man thank you man I heard
everything you do now I'm humbled
you